hello everyone we're gonna spend some
time talking about how to lead a
data-driven digital transformation and
this is what every leader should know
I'm Rey Wong with constellation research
and I want to start with this back 61%
of the fortune 500 have been gone
they've been merged acquired but I'm
bankrupt since 2000 think about that
that is the pace of change that has been
happening since 2000 these are business
models these are organizations
transforming and in the process taking
out the competitors I want you to take
some time and follow along what do you
think is the hottest performing stock
since 2000 I'm gonna put some names up
here you can guess
yell out loud tell me what you're
hearing alright the fangs over another
one just for fun are you guys ready I'm
gonna do the countdown 5 4 3 2 are you
ready
here it is Domino's Pizza that is the
number one top performing stock since
2010 now this is an incredible story of
transformation Domino's actually won the
battle for transformation
think about it how often do you order
the pizza a week right and when you
order that pizza think about it what
happens you're on the app and at 4 p.m.
suddenly a notification shows up and
says would you like a pizza and most
people say yes now behind the backend of
what is happening is a mile of data
transformation amount of data that's
actually happening and a massive digital
transformation effort right once you
order that pizza it sets off everything
inventory supply chains it sets off the
kitchen the kitchen knows that the guy
get this pizza in and delivered by 30
minutes or less right and you get a
status you know that the pizza order has
been taken unit the pizza is in the oven
you know the pizza is 10 minutes away
five minutes away and 2 minutes away
from your door and in fact you never had
to pull any cash you can pay everything
on the app that is what we're talking
about and in fact if you even try you
can actually take a picture of the pizza
it goes into an AI ml engine and they
test
the quality of that pizza that is what
we're talking about it has a major
transformation that curves now we can
say Domino's won the digital
transformation war but really win and
actually there's something that's
actually happening right because we are
seeing that this is the foundation every
single digital business the ability to
bring data they better bring these
inputs be able to put all the signal
intelligence in play and the bowl here
it's about getting to precision
decisions that decision velocity becomes
a very important piece now why are
precision decisions so hard how do we
get there how do we come successful well
there's a reason these are hard right
it's really because we've got so many
data sources there's data all over the
place it's in a mainframe it's sitting
over on an app it's an an IOT device
it's sitting on three other clouds and
that makes it very hard now
that also brings us to the point that we
have complex data environment these
environments are crazy right
and there's also all these privacy rules
and requirements and data residency and
suddenly data is encrypted some data is
not encrypted we got to pull all this
together and then of course there's a
lot of external data sources - we're not
just talking about the stuff that's in
your control we're talking about weather
feeds we're talking about social media
we're talking about videos from other
places written about chat and this has
to come together and then of course we
also have this low process of getting
stuff into a date or a house getting
into the data right and this is not easy
to do bring all this data together and
then it gets even worse right the speed
that's required the speed you want to
make a decision right away if you're
doing a credit check right now you're
not gonna wait 10 minutes right if
someone's defrauding your ATM you're not
gonna wait five minutes you want to know
that something is happening and so we
gotta bring all this together I'm gonna
do it very quickly to get to that
precision decision now there is a lot of
change that's going on with data we have
to understand that this data there's a
lot of it right I'm not gonna read all
the stats you can follow along but the
most important one for me is really the
last one 70% of your mission-critical
data is not even in your
or walls it's coming from external
sources and we've got a drop that data
we've got to manage that data and some
piece you're gonna transform that data
secure it and deliver it and it is a
pain it is not easy to do right and so
we have this insight supply chain that
starts with all the upstream data
sources everything comes in and then we
gotta bring this stuff in we're gonna
figure what is going on right so let's
classify that data that's transform it
so it fits in the roots of what we want
it to do and we going to admit and have
different tags add different sources AG
differents metadata on top of it and
then when we master it sure that data
I'm gonna figure out who did deliver it
to right where does it go right as an
external source is it active is it
inactive do we take it out of the system
right and then of course we have to
figure how to refresh that and that
cycle goes on and on every time so once
we make sure that then we can start
thinking about how we can get to the
data to decisions life cycle this is
extremely important how we take data all
types of data structured unstructured
semi-structured and then we align that
to a business process it becomes
powerful ordered a cash campaign to lead
hire to retire incident a resolution
procure to pay and you notice there's a
line there that line shows you what the
tech team is doing the top part is what
the business side wants to do I want to
take those patterns and I want to figure
out what is the insight and I want to
understand that insight and when I
understand and say then I want to take
that and I want to take action and make
decisions sometimes making no decision
as a decision but if you look at this it
becomes a cycle we then take that and
come back over and over again now we're
doing these things today in many cases
in batch it's taken forever right we got
to make decisions in milliseconds yeah
decisions in milliseconds and this is
white decision velocity is important
getting to precision decisions now one
of the ways to get there is when we
apply machine learning and automation
and we've got to answer that question is
when do we automate things and we've got
seven tests of when automation makes
sense and when you apply human powered
approaches so when things are highly
repetitive that's something you don't
want to have humans do what do we do
we get tired we make mistakes we get a
little bit lazy right we get sloppy
because we're trying over and over again
we are totally bored right and that's
where you want to apply something that's
AI powered when we think about what
actually happens with lots of volume
we're overwhelmed we can't possibly do
all that on our own and that's another
area where we go to automation and then
of course when the time the completion
is quick while humans don't scale very
well when there's lots of interaction
humans once again get overwhelmed and
confuse there so much happening I can
probably maybe happen one two maybe
three things at once and that's really
pushing the limits but when you're
interacting with all these devices all
these connections and have to make those
decisions quickly that's where the power
of automation comes in however things
that are complex they cannot be modeled
by math that's where we actually see
humans kind of play a role and we start
to learn we apply humans and machines
and we bring them together when things
are very creative that requires to think
outside of the box or were humans we
make the rules and we are really good at
breaking the rules and once that's in
place we also think about fine motor
skills and that's another area where
automation doesn't always do a great job
but these are important things because
we have four important questions these
are the most important questions you
have to answer as we enter this
autonomous decade one when you trust
intelligent machine automation
completely what though
let it all happen with the machine right
when do we admit the machine with the
human because we want to understand the
nuance we understand why something is
not working when do you make those
exceptions because 99.99% accuracy and
medical medicine might not even be
enough we might actually have to get it
down to the point it's eight nines and
that's gonna be interesting in an 8
Sigma quality situation and then the
third question we ask is how do we
automate the human with the machine so
humans can make quicker decisions we can
make the suggestions we can make the
recommendations and then in what
processes do you always trust human
judgement these are the questions we're
gonna apply to every single business
process that we think about that
transformation now why do you want to do
this we don't do artificial intelligence
and AI just for fun we do it because we
have outcomes we want to achieve first
Tommy what's going on what is that
perception then give me a notification
give me an alert when something happened
because that's way too much information
I can't see everything at once so let's
filter down to the important things and
then after that help me make a
recommendation you've seen what I've
done before make a suggestion and every
time I reply to that suggestion I have a
digital feedback loop you know why I
chose something and why and where that
goes and you have the attribution you've
got context on when where why you know
what process hours and who I was with
right and that helps us to learn and
over time I want you to automate those
recommendations and then after a while
all that information builds on each
other and we can start making
predictions and forecasts and
understanding what might happen and then
we get to one of the most important
things you can possibly do it is about
mitigating risk prevention is so
important now let me explain you know
when we look back there used to be I
mean if you imagine you have a massive
recall a massive recall so one
manufacturer had a massive recall it was
like 150 phones took out eight billion
dollars over eight weeks that's crazy
now if we could apply machine learning
artificial intelligence to drive down
the ability to triangulate a problem we
could take it from eight weeks to one
week and that would be a billion dollar
recall to go from one week to one day
would be a hundred million dollar recall
what's a million dollars to solve that
problem to save a hundred million and
even eight billion dollars and that's
where you see the power of AI really in
helping you mitigate the risk figure out
compliance one fine and gdpr could cost
you three percent of your revenues not
profits your revenues and their we start
to see some of the benefits that are out
there now what else is happening well
we've got a couple things we have to do
to be able to get there we have to
figure out how do we outpace the speed
of business this is important the pace
of change is happening so quickly we
need ways to catch up we need ways to
get to that automation for that
transformation to occur the other pieces
we want to work faster but we can't do
that in human scale and how do we
deliver that in human scale it's gonna
take some time and so we've got to
figure out when we automate automate and
augment our manual processes that's an
important piece we asked those four
questions earlier and the reason we have
to do that is there are some processes
that will never be
automated that have to have a human
intervention but there's so many
processes that we have to think about or
we can bring that automation to achieve
that data transformation and then the
other piece that's important is the
scenarios that happen they're complex
they're complex business scenarios that
require some thought in terms of both
the business models and the monetization
models that are behind it and then of
course we have to figure out how to get
to the next best action how do you
remember these books
choose-your-own-adventure one of my
favorites right well what is that next
best action how do you make that choice
how do you get there to be successful
and then of course one of the things
that we can deliver is mass
personalization at scale that's not
something we can do manually that's
something we want to be able to deliver
in terms of figuring out personalization
getting the Preferences getting all the
context that's required figuring out the
restrictions maybe you have a food
allergy you can't eat peanuts you can't
eat milk maybe you don't have certain
types of meats that you are religiously
unable to you can consume them and so we
want to be able to capture that and
bring that to life and then of course
there are other things we can do we can
do dynamic pricing and pricing
optimization taking networks and
understand demand signal supply signals
using that to figure out we efficiently
pricing our pricing our offerings and
putting that into work so and then of
course regulatory compliance is a big
issue right where can we actually make
sure we meet what we need to do if
you're in highly regulated industries
this is very important because you don't
want your best people figuring out
regulatory compliance that's an area
where you want to do massive amounts of
automation massive amounts of software
scale and where you can is being
preventive about that on the AI side and
then we talked about mitigating risk if
we can actually mitigate the risk of a
bankruptcy risk of a bad filing risk of
actually doing something that you know
takes down billions of dollars of your
company or even hundreds of dollars of
your company that's a very important
piece and figuring out how to actually
get that to scale so how do we get there
how do we become successful well we've
got to figure out how to get to speed
speed is so important how do we actually
make decisions quicker there's a concept
that we call decision velocity and I've
been talking about it
decision velocity is ability to get to
that faster decisions you can make the
more likely you're going to succeed and
even beat the competition I'll give you
an example today bots can actually
operate at a hundred decisions per
second humans at best can respond in
maybe an hour but we have to go through
the organizational structure and that
might even take a day to get to a
decision
so first are making hundreds of
decisions per second and humans are only
making a decision maybe a half day we've
got a problem and imagine if that's your
competitors that are putting automation
and AI to work you are already at least
exponentially behind so speed becomes a
role ease-of-use is also super important
aren't billing to actually access that
information see it visualize it
utilize it in a way so that we've
democratized that information so people
can quickly make decisions that
visualization is so important because
that ease of use means that I can pick
it up in any device I'm using I can
actually do it in any context of a
business process and that actually helps
me get to that transformation and then
of course we have to make sure these are
industry ready and business ready you
know the name of a customer is different
when you're in healthcare because that's
a patient when you're in legal and
professional services that's a client
right and so when we think about the
role of a customer it's very very
different the language is different the
industries are different the regulations
are different now some value chains are
similar to each other and they will
collapse and we can work with each other
we can work through them so things comms
media entertainment in telco those have
converged because you're selling content
you're using different networks with
distribution and the technology enables
that so that you can deliver it to every
customer now contextually relevant is
important now you might want to know why
I put the slide up here
I've always wanted to use the Easter
Island slides IPT away these heads are
here and that's my point on context
irrelevant why what's the location
what's the time where am i right what
business process am i happy am I feeling
great did it have a great experience
before potentially relevant becomes an
important distribution
the ability to actually drag and drop
the ability to use containers the
ability use things like kubernetes the
ability to actually you know take micro
services and bring them together that's
where it gets very exciting and then of
course it has to be secure security is
such
an important factor especially given
today with the DDoS attacks the DNI
attacks all the things are actually
happening we want to make sure that the
data secure it's encrypted it to be able
to use and then of course once we have
all it together
we can start thinking about potential
use cases so let's take a look what's
going on what are some use cases well
the first one is we want to be able to
transform old industries with new tech
this is about thinking about brand new
types of business models and we give you
an example here so how many of you
actually fill out the warranty card for
a toaster come on fills out the warranty
card for a toaster anybody now usually
in a room of like a thousand maybe five
thousand people when I feel like two or
three people that fill out the warranty
card now you don't have to answer that
question but let me explain why it's so
important imagine the first phone call
that's made to the manufacturer of that
toaster do people ever come saying oh I
love your toaster it is amazing
no they don't do that that first phone
call is a call about two things one my
toaster is broken can you help me fix it
or two I don't know how to use something
those are typically the problems that
you get on the first call now the
interesting challenge is the toaster
manufacturer does not know who the
customer on that phone call it is a
horrible experience because for 10
minutes that poor set poor rep is trying
to figure out like where did you get the
toaster what model is that toaster when
did you purchase that toaster right and
sometimes they figure out it's not even
their toaster so okay so we get this
kind of situation but think about that
first phone call that's toasters
probably $40 that first phone call takes
about 30 minutes to diagnose the problem
you're already at negative MPs and
you've turned five dollars of the profit
or maybe even the revenue of that and
you've completely destroyed all your
profit on that first phone call because
your call center cost or maybe $15 an
hour that is a crazy proposition so let
me change the proposition and ask you
this question if I told you connect that
toaster to the Internet and if you do
that we will make sure we monitor the
health of that toaster protect your
privacy all you have to do is provide us
maybe a text number maybe an email
what are you comfortable with
and we will monitor that toaster and if
there's a defect we'll let you know if
there is a potential problem or an
upgrade that we have to tell you about
we'll let you know - and 90 days before
that toasters gonna die we will give you
a warning would you take that off for
now would you like register your toaster
now if you said yes thank you because
now I can actually do a bunch of things
I can actually create a whole bunch of
opportunities with that toaster because
I didn't say hey I'm remote monitoring
your toaster and there's something bad
that's about to happen you know would
you like to buy a new toaster and you
might take the offer and I might even
give you the offer for the same price
you paid for 10 years ago that's pretty
cool offer right and I might even do
something different I might actually say
look would you be interested in getting
this toaster for 15 cents a month for
the next eight years we'll give you a
brand new toaster well you're thinking
hey what is that
well that's called toasts as a service
why wouldn't you do that and pretty soon
I can get to some interesting things if
you say yes on the toaster I might make
you an offer and other kitchen
appliances and say look I will do your
entire kitchen for $100 a month and if
any product ever dies or fails you get
your brand-new one we will make sure we
monitor the health of those products
we'll make sure that all the safety is
there and that's all you have to pay
hundred dollars a month right what have
we done we've created five different
business models built on data and this
is the digital transformation we're
talking about first one we're doing
customer experience monitoring we're
making sure that the products okay we
want to know what's going on now I got a
very interesting question for you why do
bagels cost a lot of problems and
toasters right and that's really what I
really wanted to ask you why did they do
what does that happen
why are you bagels cost runs and so we
can actually see some very interesting
regional regional statistics you will
see that maybe in New York the bagels
are actually causing more problems than
perhaps in London right where you don't
see a lot of bagels and that's the type
of thing that we're studying - and then
that customer experience monitoring
we're trying to figure out hey what are
the most common problems that are
occurring right
why do toasters break more in Houston
Texas than in Dubai think about it what
could it be what could be humidity and
something we can actually do customer
experience monitoring track down
problems understand what customer is
experiencing and actually improve our
products the second
and we can do remote field service
anything that's kind of broken remote
diagnostics we can fix that ahead of
time so you don't have to send someone
out there and you can actually keep
people in a warranty plan the third
piece we still only have a services
model toast as a service think about it
for 15 cents a month for the next eight
years we will take care of your toaster
it's a great deal and we'll get your
replacement if anything breaks we'll
take care of that and then of course we
have the ability to go direct to
consumer
that means the toaster manufacturer who
traditionally sell to ret retailer can
now go to direct they can actually offer
something to them and then of course the
cross-sell will do your entire kitchen
five business models off of data and
that's just a toaster that could be an
appliance that could be your car that
could be any manufacturer good what
you're actually providing these
capabilities this is the power of the
transformation we're talking about the
second piece we've got a rethink and
event brand new types of business models
and these could actually be in a
different form and let's take the same
vein let me make you an offer here for
$15 a month I'm gonna give you an 85
inch screen TV for seven years and a
free upgrade would you take that would
you take that deal now you're like wait
what's the catch what's gonna happen
like why did I do that well you know
it's actually a really good deal you're
spending less than $1,000 and you get a
free upgrade for an awesome brand-new TV
and if you were to say yes well what
would the business be the manufacturer
of that TV or someone else in a warranty
plan could provide a very cool offer
they would go and figure out hey what
products are better which one has a
Treader track record they would take
data from a company like Best Buy and
say hey which one breaks more who's got
a better track record and then pretty
soon they won't be able to make an offer
to you like what we did and every
manufacturer mundo Direct a consumer or
a new player could emerge that says I'll
take care of everyone's TVs and if they
did that they would have a brand new
type of business model the manufacturers
suddenly have more information about
which components break more which
features are being used
why are those feature being used and of
course what it does it allows you the
ability to think about how to actually
take all your broken defect and actually
apply that to reinsurance and so
suddenly in a manual
factor is the insurer the manufacturer
is now insuring and they've got the
capability to keep these units in there
and if you did this for the next three
to five years well you can actually
dominate a market and you'd be able to
actually say look I'm gonna guarantee
your TV doesn't matter what the brand is
it's good for eighty five inches and
will take care of you for fifteen
dollars a month for seven years for
seven years you will lock every customer
down that's a pretty good thing and you
can start offering other things back to
the kitchen and maybe I'll do your HVAC
unit I'll be your air conditioning and
heating for you so that's one option now
the only thing is we are building what
we call data-driven digital networks
these data-driven digital networks are
happening everyone it's about buoyant
roster from value chains is about
converging industry value chains and
actually getting something interesting
so manufacturing retail and distribution
could be one chain right healthcare
insurance right and public sector could
be one chain and we're seeing that
collapsing of different industries so
what we need to do to get started well
it's very exciting right you know first
of all we've got to start with answering
the business question ask questions that
you don't have an answer to right
normally you would ask a question to say
yeah you know how is the number of
marketing leads what's coming in or
house our performance in terms of
revenue you know per unit sale okay
great that's interesting but when you
start asking questions outside of
departments it gets a little tricky
right oh but I don't have the data oh
that's a point you want to be able to
ask the right business question do I
bring in ten more FTEs in marketing or
do I spend a million dollars on a
campaign when it's very valid question
but Ray I don't know what the answer is
I don't know how to get there
well that's okay ask the question first
and then let's go figure out where to
find the data sources once we understand
where the data sources are we now have
the opportunity to then do something
different we can then bring that
information together help visualize it
differently look at this part right here
this heat map I want to know why those
areas are brown don't you or what's deep
blue versus what's light blue and what
you're trying to do is help people ask
the right questions understand how to
use the data understand how those
questions result in how you actually
organize that data and what do you
search for and bring together
then what we want to do is connect it to
the right people right we know the
questions we know the flow in the
process we are building data proficiency
then well we've got to go out and
connect it the right people so they can
make the right decisions and they
surface up those decisions at the right
time and once that's in place it's got
to look cool right you've got to get
awesome visualization you've got to be
able to see what's going on and when you
have that in place then you understand
okay
now I can actually use that data if you
can put that used to be successful okay
so we talked about all this we also be
have to think about the ethical use of
that data and of course in AI and we've
got five rules to get you there right
those five rules are part of the first
one it's gonna be transparent you got to
see what's going on right you can
understand the algorithms you can
understand why those items are there
right and then you've got to figure out
if there are biases you're gonna be
explaining them now biases aren't a bad
thing if you're deliberately
discriminating against you know a
left-hander is with purple hair or not
deliberately and you found that you've
done that we've got a problem right so
but if the bias is there because you're
selecting for certain things and certain
characteristics that are really
important like for example you might to
have to have military training to be
able to get into a secure location you
might to have to have a certain skill in
math maybe you have to have a certain
skill in communications to really get a
job totally make sense but you gotta
build explain it and once you can
explain it right if there's a problem
like bias which we talked about we got
to be able to reverse it and learn
something that's wrong and then of
course once that's in place we got a big
train these systems these systems take
years I told you this earlier right
imagine 90% accuracy manufacturing
that's not a problem that's probably
okay right but we got to figure what the
exceptions are ninety percent accuracy
in healthcare no way ninety percent
Actress in a Thomas driving no way when
there's lives involved
we're expecting higher degrees of
quality and precision and then once
that's in place we always have this fear
like oh my god the machines are taking
over
they're gonna come attack us all right
well if you're afraid of that you start
every process with a human and you end a
process with the human as a check all
right I said I got it five simple rules
these are design principles for AI
ethics something you want to make sure
you apply as we're talking about it okay
so we talked a lot 61% of a fortune 500
merge acquired got
since 2000 massive amounts of change are
in place we have to think about how we
get started the first part is we're
building new experiences and outcomes in
this transformation so think about what
that is
apply Design Thinking a pile of empathy
start with that put yourself in the
customers shoes and then we got to
figure out how we actually build a
culture of digital what's that digital
DNA let's make sure folks can bring a
right-brain left-brain activities
together they've got the data
proficiency to be successful and then
when we have that in place form always
follows function right form follows
function get the business model right
and the monetization model right first
and then we can figure out which cool
technologies to apply right of course we
gotta start in the cloud of course
there's gonna be machine learning and AI
and then maybe on the edge there's IOT
and something else maybe we're using
computer vision and augmented reality
and virtual reality putting that all
together right and of course form
follows function now once we have that
in place we've got a ship from gut
driven to data-driven decisions we're
using data to advance Ford we're
figuring out what products work we'll
figure out why something happens and we
gotta have that data in place and once
we have a data in place we can start
figuring out how to build the patterns
how to automate and then of course
applying the a either and then of course
this isn't easy if this was easy you
could just buy in a package and be done
and so a lot of this transformation
requires you to clone of a and co-create
with partners remember we can't do it
alone you want a cone of eight and
co-create with partners and if you put
all this in place we're ready we're
ready to do this data driven
transformation that's out there for you
so thank you very much if you've got any
questions please feel free reach out to
me happy to help you have a great event